Adam 22 and Destiny have just been
talking [__] about me for months and
it's really interesting because Destiny
if you look up Destiny Pearl there's all
of these streams of this man just like
seething on stream talking about me I
mean what what can I say I'm a character
and and um you know Destiny has been
saying for months Pearl Pearl you're
just falling off oh Pearl Pearl and it's
really interesting cuz I call them the
pocket Watcher content creators content
creators that are always pocket watching
they're like oh oh you're not making
enough money oh oh oh and they're always
speculating how much you're making and
always and it's usually because
typically they're falling off I mean I
haven't heard of Destiny really doing
much um if I had to say anyone that's
the CEO of grifting I I would say that's
Destiny I mean right now he's currently
grifting on bore you know he he did a
debate with Nick Fuentes and and Destiny
and he Destiny got absolutely destroyed
you know he clearly didn't know what he
was talking about now he's coming back
again and pretending to be a war expert
but you know who who am I to say so so
now there's a video going viral of Adam
22 interviewing Destiny let's pull it up
do you think your girl would be mad if
you [__] just pearly things me yeah I
don't
know I haven't really thought about man
like she had like a very like rise of
star trajectory and then she just like
started talking to like more people and
then they just here's here's the two
issues with J pearly things okay one is
her growth was never as explosive as
people thought it was she hardcore gamed
the shorts algorithm okay like that 1.5
million Subs that's like 200,000 Subs
right cuz if you look at her long form
content she struggles to get like I
think 150,000 views on a video um with
like over 1.5 million Subs on the
channel so that's the first up secondly
she was growing in kind of the pocket of
all of that red pill stuff exploding and
now people have kind of uh you know let
the hair out let the air out of the tire
a little bit it's kind of deflating a
bit and so she's like she blew up on
these shorts and then she's kind of like
drifting here and then all the other red
pilled stuff is kind of like whatever
and she's just kind of like because she
in my opinion not to be mean or rude to
her I don't know if she offers much in
terms of her individuality that people
would want to stick around for right
like as much as I might not like their
beliefs I could understand why people
would watch like myON I know why people
watch fresh I know why people watch and
your T well they have enduring fan base
Yeah Yeah well yeah but like even as
individuals even people like Rolo and
stuff I can understand why people are
fans of those people but how many people
are fans of pearl it's interesting I
didn't even see this clip until I went
on SAS cast in Miami and they read this
to me and I thought it was funny because
the same month um Destiny says I'm I'm
falling off oh pearls just falling off
which I don't really care you know I
just give my opinions you guys can take
them or leave them you know whatever um
and the same month that Destiny says
pearls just falling off d
I go on Pierce Morgan I get one of their
most viewed clips of all
time I mean let me know when you come on
Pierce Morgan Destiny it I wanted to
point out that a lot of times with these
content creators they're so focused on
what all of the other content creators
are doing they almost Miss really
creating new original content cuz
they're too busy reacting they're too
busy pocket watching every other content
creator known to man it's doing pretty
good it's better than any of your videos
yeah that's for sure I mean wait what is
the biggest YouTube video you ever
dropped was it Vape Nation back when you
were like still kind of culturally
relevant well it was cool cuz you used
to make stuff and now you just critique
stuff and there's a big difference
between people like me and people like
you yeah what happened I think everyone
that's your fan wants to know where did
it all go wrong I think people are
pretty happy I don't think so I think a
lot of people I mean if you look at the
cultural relevance and contributions I
mean you contributing now you're just
kind of coming
after yeah well well here's where it is
was it the money or was it the
fame it funny if you just answered the
questions what do you want me to say
what do you want say I want you to tell
me why you stopped making things oh yeah
so okay well let first of all let me
remind you this is my [__] show yeah
well it sucks and so I just responded
I'm just a responder okay I am only
pointing this stuff out because they
they talk about me first Destiny says
nobody cares what I have to say yet has
been reacting to me for months I'm like
Destiny you care what I have to say and
that's the funny thing I'm like all
right yeah no one cares okay anyways so
you know I'm just busy I'm
busy you know I'm just I'm super
busy just hating my life and falling off
and just doing terrible and it's just so
terrible now
um so okay so that's the Twitter beef of
the day